hey i'm praya i'm 26 years old my name
is erica i'm 37 years old
my name is matt edwards i was diagnosed
with covet in july
i contracted covert on march 23rd
seven months into my covert journey and
it is now october i still haven't
recovered from
any of the crippling fatigue nearly
seven months later and i'm still
unwell i am still a broken woman
[Music]
by now we all know the most common
symptoms of kovid 19
dry cough the high fever
the loss of taste or smell but
some people are beginning to feel the
long-term effects of coronavirus
some of these symptoms are having a
devastating impact
on people's lives the first two weeks
were relatively easy looking back
and it just got worse the more i
relapsed a lot of people talk about
having a fatigue that can't get like a
state of being at three o'clock in the
morning
all day long and that's kind of the way
that mine is
i could not even walk to the bathroom
alone the fatigue is so bad
i couldn't sit in the shower and wash my
hair i didn't have the energy to keep my
arms above my head
extreme fatigue is an often reported
symptom
but long covet seems to affect every
part of the body
with people reporting cognitive
difficulties anxiety depression
and headaches it can cause heart
problems such as irregular heartbeat
chest pain lung problems such as
shortness of breath
and gastrointestinal problems like
diarrhea
the way that i explain it to people is
it's kind of like getting up out of bed
in the morning
and then reaching your hand in a hat you
have to pull out a symptom
and you got like you know maybe 50
different symptoms that you can pull out
and then whatever you pull out of the
hat is
what you have for the day i was 26 when
i got it and i was so healthy i had no
underlying health conditions
no prior illnesses and here i am seven
months later and
i have heart irregular heartbeat heart
palpitations chest pain
really bad um brain issues muscle spasms
numbing all of this as a 26 year old and
i just think long covert needs to be
part of the discussion because at the
moment all it is is
older people are going to die
the nhs estimates around 60 000 people
in england could be suffering from long
covert symptoms more than three months
after catching the virus
it could be more it could be less and
because kovat19
is relatively new there is still a lot
we don't know about the long-term
offense we find that of all the people
that are symptomatic with covid
about one in 20 will actually have
symptoms still
at two months afterwards and one in 45
will have symptoms for longer than three
months
it does seem that having more than five
symptoms in the first week
seems to be a strong risk factor for
long covid it's slightly more likely if
you're
a female and this may be something to do
with the difference in immune response
to viruses in women and men
it is a mentally testing it's it's not
something i would wish on
even my worst enemy there have also been
reports of the impact of long covered on
mental health
causing anxiety and stress that's the
most untalked about thing
and also the most challenging thing they
just can't believe the amount of
messages i get each day from people
saying no one believes me
they think you know it's just mental
illness and they're just delusional
it's really awful and it's only because
it's not being spoken about enough
well for example my wife's a nurse and
uh
and you know she she's regularly trying
to be there for me with it but
you know she's regularly seeing patients
in the icu
every day with covid and then she sees
me you know
dealing with still symptoms way after
the fact and
it's even hard for her to understand at
times because she had coveted too
and it didn't affect her that way i had
three migraines yesterday
i was an absolute emotional mess i had
nothing under control i was just
crying the whole afternoon it makes you
question yourself a lot
you know are you just seeing things are
you just experiencing things like
i have a super understanding amazing
employer
for now i'm okay but if of course this
goes on for too much longer i don't know
what the situation is of course
my sick leave is not unlimited
now that more evidence of long covert is
coming to light there have been calls
for more support to be made available
health secretary matt hancock has even
been asked about
it in parliament people of all ages
affect are affected by long covert
and people who are who are younger who
might think that they're unlikely to get
severe symptoms or die
of covid can still have a terrible
illness
that completely changes their lives for
months months and months
the uk government responded by
announcing a 10 million pound
investment in october 2020 to fund long
covert clinics
across england it follows the setup of a
clinic in the italian city of genoa
also looking into sufferers of long
covet i think this is vitally needed
whether 10 million pounds is going to be
enough to deal with this
we've yet to see i think it may need
considerable more funding than that
but i think this is really great that
the government has put forward this
funding
without official guidance people have
been finding comfort in sharing their
experiences
on online forums one long covered
facebook page
has tens of thousands of members who
post stories of their relapses
symptoms and recovery being able to be
on a support group on facebook has
probably helped more than anything i
mean that's the only thing that sort of
kept me sane because
when you hear so many people have it and
when everyone's saying it's just a
two-week illness
and you'll get over it and you're not by
month three and then month four
and month five and you're still so
unwell it's so unnerving and the only
thing that keeps you sane
is talking to other people who have long
covered i was of course
thinking well maybe i have a terminal
illness maybe maybe i've got some
some form of cancer that i've been you
know
stricken with and
of course after several tests it was
none of those things
um and being able to be a part of a
support group and knowing that there are
so many other people who all have the
same neurological symptoms as me
uh as really helped
that's the only you know framework
around the pandemic is that
young people will probably be okay and
that older people might die
but that's not the truth there are
there's this whole in between which are
thousands of people are getting long
covered and there's no
answers seek whatever support you can in
my case
the support groups have been more help
than any doctors or any medical
professionals
so far so make sure that you you make
friends in the same situation